[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: We're about to
celebrate our 10th anniversary
of Android.
SPEAKER 2: Welcome to developing
Android apps in Kotlin.
SPEAKER 3: Android
Studio 3.1 is now
available for download or
update in the stable channel.
SPEAKER 4: We're
introducing Android Jetpack,
our next generation of
components and tools
along with architecture guidance
designed to help you accelerate
your Android development.
SPEAKER 5: With the launch of
Jetpack and the KTX libraries,
we've made Android development
even sweeter in Kotlin.
SPEAKER 6: We've introduced a
new publishing format called
the Android App Bundle.
SPEAKER 7: Well, today we're
announcing Android P Beta.
Android P Beta is available
on Google Pixel and seven more
manufacturer flagship
devices today.
SPEAKER 8: We're about to see
a whole new form factor idea
from Android device makers.
Foldables, so the screen
can literally bend and fold.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Developers
influence the platform.
You're not on top of it,
you're a part of what we do.
SPEAKER 9: We heard you wanted
more, so we're building more.
SPEAKER 10: I'm really excited
for the release of Android
Studio 3.3, bringing
important features
and more coming in 2019.
SPEAKER 6: I am excited
for next year, where
we're going to continue
to make content
for the next generation
of Android devs.
SPEAKER 11: I'm happy to see
a steady update of Kotlin
adoption in Android apps.
SPEAKER 12:
Architecture components
in combination
with Kotlin, that's
what's brought my code
to the next level.